- Well, taking a turn.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- I hear that there's also a skill
that you've discovered
(Cara gasps)
that you have, and it
doesn't have to do with the
- (unintelligible).
- Yeah. (chuckling)
- Yeah.
- No. Not--
(both laughing)
- I love you so much!
- So you do do that!
- So you do do this!
- So you can read lips?
(Kelly and Cara laugh)
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God!
(laughing continues)
- I'm gonna pee my pants!
- [Cara] Wait.
- Season two of Cara's show--
- So you can-- Are you--?
(Kelly cackles)
(Cara claps)
- Are you guessing
- what I'm saying?
- How do you do--?
- How to you know?
(applauding)
(laughing)
- Can you read lips, or minds?
- Please say you do this
- when you're on a date
- with someone.
- Have you?
(audience laughing)
(Kelly wheezing)
- My God. I swear to God
- I swear to God
- I might have peed
- a little bit.
(audience laughing and applauding)
- Oh my God. Oh my God.